تم تسجيل أن
هذا الحزب الخيالي كان اجتماع عمل
ولم يكن بعيدًا اجتماعيًا
[موسيقى]
لذا
يبدو أن ملاحظات [الموسيقى] تلقي الضوء على
القواعد التي كان الناس يفعلون كل
شيء للامتثال
لها ولم يكن ذلك في نيتي مطلقًا ،
وسأأسف على هذه الملاحظات بسبب
بقية أيامي والآن على
اعتذاري العميق لكم جميعًا في المنزل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السيد المتحدث ، هل لي أن
أبدأ بالقول إنني
أتفهم وأشارك
الغضب في جميع أنحاء البلاد عندما رأيت
الموظفين رقم 10
يبدو أنهم يسلطون الضوء  تدابير الإغلاق
وأستطيع أن أفهم
كيف أنه من الغضب الاعتقاد
بأن الأشخاص الذين وضعوا
القواعد لم يتبعوا القواعد
السيد المتحدث لأنني كنت غاضبًا أيضًا
لرؤية ذلك المقطع
والسيد المتحدث الذي
أعتذر عنه ،
فأنا أعتذر بلا تحفظ  الإساءة
التي تسببت بها في جميع أنحاء
البلاد وأعتذر عن
الانطباع الذي أعطته
[موسيقى]